is it nice to see your face on a book
did you ever think that was gonna happen
i've never no i i never really did think
i would see my uh my face on a book it's
pretty awesome yeah it's a pretty cool
book to be on the on the cover of
absolutely it's a great series um but
before we get to that it was yesterday
yesterday was your birthday right it was
yes
um i had i the day before i got i got a
hall pass to go golf which was pretty
fun and then yesterday i had a very
low-key day spent it with my daughters
and my wife
and i cooked some steaks at home and it
was pretty fun that's amazing um i was
just listening to your smartlist on the
way over here and i was particularly i
liked the uh the idea of having
10 movies for jack to watch yeah that's
a good idea mine aren't old enough to do
that yet but i was wondering like is
jack in love with being a big brother
now
yeah he does a great job as a big
brother yeah uh you know he's there's a
big age separation he's nine and my two
girls are
21 months and just a month now and so he
does a great job he's so sweet with them
and and
they love him so much and and they miss
him when he's gone and they love him so
much hi constance seeing you yet
you look beautiful oh my gosh thank you
so look at you wow
katie bierneck she sure cleans up well
doesn't she she spilled the beans about
this uh chocolate infused bacon
the other night what's the deal with
this is this like are we gonna start
marketing this we're gonna get this out
to the world if i had enough to get out
to the whole world i sure would but yeah
i thought still water at our at our
ranch we've got we're experimenting with
all kinds of delicious pork mostly it's
hazelnuts uh hazelnut infused pork it's
pretty spectacular that's amazing how
did doing this show feel you know not
only as a performer in it but also as an
executive producer
it's a lot of work really i mean
obviously
i was honored to be able to do it i'm
not complaining but it's my first foray
into bringing something from a book on
the screen and being you know a big and
critical part of every step along the
way
20 years i've been in this business and
i've always been acting so i show up to
do a little rehearsal do the fittings
step on the mark and go to work
kind of fail to really recognize how
much goes into just getting to that
point and so it was definitely
eye-opening uh
and a great learning experience and you
know i think
if you're smart and you're in this
business for a long time you want to
find ways to continue to learn and
continue to grow and definitely uh did
both of those things on this job are
these conversations that you have to
have as a family because the volume of
work as an executive producer as a
performer takes you away from the family
for a long time yeah yeah and definitely
i mean this one of the benefits and one
of the reasons i really wanted to make
this show
was it was to bring some work back to
los angeles back to the southern
california area it's been years now that
i've been working but i've been shooting
on location wherever the best tax
benefits are but it was really crucial
to me
that we shoot this in los angeles
because not only does it take place in
southern california in the books but
also it's an opportunity for me to be
home be close to my family
little did i realize executive producing
and starring in a show i was going to be
gone more on this show than i was in the
when i'm gone in atlanta or london so it
was a mountain of work and and by the
grace of god i've got a very
understanding and loving wife who who
stepped up and and and took care of took
care of business at home while i was
basically
leaving before she woke up and getting
home after she gone to bed
[Music]
you